God just put us together it was like one
of those Miracle situations where it
just I didn't see it coming you know
what I mean like I thought my life was
over Gwen Stefani's loving her next
chapter with Blake Shelton Blake saved
my life everybody knows that and
everybody loves their Unexpected Love
Story
[Applause]
[Music]
you are coming up on your two-year
anniversary
with Blake Shelton God just put us
together it was like one of those
Miracle situations where it just I
didn't see it coming while appearing on
the Drew Barrymore show the singer gets
candid about her mindset after splitting
from ex-husband Gavin Rossdale I was
like I'm gonna wake up every day I'm
gonna have a coffee I'm gonna take care
of my kids and then I'm gonna go to bed
like I'm Never Gonna Kiss anyone like
I'm never gonna you know what I mean
like I thought my life was over but as
Gwen explains life was actually just
beginning and then Blake Shelton's like
hey
I'm Blake Shelton I think I think the
thing is finding a best friend and
someone that is like on the same like
plane when it comes to morals or like
just the way you look at life that's
that's the dream you know what I mean
when's one of these people that I've
learned so much from she goes on to say
her in Blake's Dynamic it's also the
secret behind that romance and just
having someone that it's like we think
the same about things yet we're so
different like he's like watching
football and doing his stuff that he
does and I'm like clean makeup on so
whatever but yet we're so the same on so
many levels yeah like when they both
praised this contestant on The Voice the
only shoe
you gotta tell us guys look at that
you're adorable what's your name my name
is Brayden lape I'm from Grass Lake
Michigan and I'm 15.
[Applause]
you're your new Mom and Dad yeah your
parents are so happy for you your new
coach parents and Gwen's throwing her
support behind Blake as he prepares to
exit the singing competition after
season 23. I wasn't ready you know what
I mean it's I have to figure out who
this new Blake's gonna be right
um but I'm just so proud of him I mean
he's brought so much joy he's so
talented and I just I know people just
wait around to to laugh and watch him on
TV so I feel sorry for everybody he's
gonna be gone and um yeah I just I just
am so proud of him meanwhile Blake just
helped honor his love at the 2022 Matrix
Awards I am humble and excited to speak
about my wonderful wife and duet partner
today as she is honored for putting
women at the Forefront and championing
women consistently throughout her
prolific career he works so much that
having him do this extra is like always
like a lot but we had a date night last
night we went out to dinner it was so
fun I'm so happy he's here
[Music]